bonjour la mort de la mort c'est bien
dépasser ses limites comme ça moi ça me
va pas ce que je préfère c'est ça sera
dans une éternité mémoire de la mort si
on y arrive a ajouté
la vie à la vie c'est encore mieux c'est
possible et maintenant tout de suite
comment en courant intelligemment
parce que l'intelligence et dans notre
corps on a vu ça tout l'après midi
donc on va voir comment alors ils se
retrouvent que à l'origine nous étions
programmés nous sommes toujours pour
courir
elle sait grâce alors imaginez que à la
place de micro g enfin la place de cette
souris qui marche pas j'ai une violence
et puis que je fais un petit trop de
chiens
j'ai un super odorat d'ailleurs on m'en
a parlé à l'instant qui me permet de
sentir qu'il ya une gazelle qui est
passé il ya 6 heures et qu'elle semble
on est que je vais me la faire je me la
manger grâce à mon endurance
est-ce que savez-vous que je peux faire
ça pendant 1000 kilomètres pendant six
jours
nous sommes programmés pour trotter ont
sur de trop tiens et ça c'est vrai c'est
pour de vrai un dock trotte pendant
pendant 1000 km donc c'est à 7km site
une marche qui nous permet on a encore
deux pieds au sol de transférer
l'énergie potentielle en cinétique
mais on est suffisamment une menace tic
pour récupérer l'énergie élastique
donc on bonifie si de cette énergie que
l'on a en courant mais en bénéficiant
aussi de la marche qui est beaucoup
moins coûteuse alors la course est dans
la nature humaine
l'évolution de l'homme fait que on a une
valise avec nous qu'ils pas un peu lourd
avec un ordinateur dedans qu'ils nous
envoient des signaux etc
mais ça nous ça nous a rendu un petit
peu cravate est serré du col et on a
perdu les capacités de
de faire ce que vous montrez bien
toujours nos chiens j'en ai deux bergers
allemands et en plus ils font de la
recherche utilitaire ce qu'ils ont un
gros nez qui marche bien alors ils vont
chercher si on est perdu alors comment
on va faire ça on est obligées donc nous
chercheurs nombreuses têtes alors on a
trouvé le moyen de réapprendre à courir
intelligemment sourit alors le plus
vieux le marathonien alors il se trouve
que heureusement il y en a certains qui
ont toujours l'intelligence de continuer
à courir et très longtemps puisque scoop
de l'année dernière le plus vieux
marathonien du monde à son nom il
serrait de courir c'était cette dernière
sa dernière course de marathon
mais il faut savoir que actuellement le
futur de l'humanité peut-être passe par
les vétérans les très anciens et nos
performances ont tellement évolué que
maintenant ce que l'on fait à 73 ans
12h58 au marathon alors certes
impression c'est à peu près 14,6 km
heure à 73 ans était le record absolu
d'olonne en 1896 souris qui se bouge un
homme dont une est quel âge at il alors
bon vous êtes jeune vous rendez pas
compte
il a 80 ans alors dans mon travail de
physiologiste je mesure ce que l'on
appelle la consommation d'oxygène vo2max
débit d'oxygène consommé au maximum à la
minute qui en fait notre capacité à
brûler des sucres et des graisses et
transformer notre énergie chimique
stocké sous forme de liaison carbone
hydrogène en énergie mécanique on a un
rendement
vous avez le très belle machine ici on a
un rendement élevé effectivement de 25%
mais avec l'élasticité et si on pour
bien on peut monter à 30 40 % c'est pour
ça que il est toujours possible
d'améliorer sa façon de courir et ça
nous permet d'augmenter notre rendement
est un entraîneur moi même puisque dans
mon passé j'ai fut sportive puis
entraîneur et puis chercheur toujours
trouvé des meilleures façons de
s'entraîner c'est mon obsession depuis
40 ans en fer en faire beaucoup moins à
l'entraînement pouvoir avoir plus de
plaisir et avoir le temps de faire plein
de choses d'autre
c'était l'objet de ma vie de mes
recherches
eh bien on est capable d'augmenter cette
consommation d'oxygène qui va nous
permettre de brûler ses sucres et ses
graisses pour les transformer en énergie
mécanique plus on consomme de l'oxygène
cumont libèrent de l'énergie mécanique
et on va pouvoir bouger vite manger de
la viande tue et les gazelles manger de
viande avant des protéines devenir
intelligent et c'est la force pour les
faire plein de choses je suis pas
végétarienne vous l'aurez compris désolé
pour les auditeurs américains ou vegan
qu'ils sont très végétal rien alors donc
c'est parce qu'à force de fréquenter des
chiens je suis désolé voilà c'est vrai
en plus donc ce jeune homme a plein de
projets il a une consommation d'oxygène
de 33 minutes kg minutes ce qui dépasse
largement qui est celle de quelqu'un de
là je suis sûre dans la salle y en a qui
ont quand cette valeur est qu'en 25 ans
parce qu'effectivement cette énergie
humaine
plus on s'en sert plus elle augmente et
moins on s'en sert plus diminue si la
seule énergie que le monde quand on s'en
sert et inversement
donc il faudrait peut-être commencer par
cas votre propre transition énergétique
puisque l'écologie on en parle beaucoup
mais on a oublié l'énergie comme j'ai vu
plein d'éoliennes en venant ici
mais moi je fais du vent
mais je préfère encore faire sa marque
et quand je fais ça je fais du mouvement
aussi bon qu en plus je me réchauffe
donc j'économise de l'énergie thermique
alors dont tu vas 80 ans il a plein de
projets il veut faire moins de 4 euros
marathon elle ceci dit en passant 3h50
c'est son but
c'est la moyenne des performances du
marathon de paris
les cinquante mille personnes qui vont
faire le marathon no 3 avril à paris
cinquante mille qui prennent le départ
et parce qu'on a limité les inscriptions
à 50 mines
sinon il y en aurait beaucoup plus et
donc ça c'est la moyenne 3 heures 50 des
50000 personnes qui font de marathon de
paris sauf que lui il a 80 ans et la
moyenne d'âge à paris ses 44 ans ça veut
dire qu'on ne plus en plus de personnes
courent de plus en plus tard et c'est
peut-être ça qui est intéressant pour
ajouter de la vie à la vie c'est
finalement de produire de l'énergie
d'autres monter notre vo2max jusque très
très très très longtemps sourit alors
deux autres devinettes et oui quel âge
at il
le jeune homme qui est là qui fait alors
voyez cette courte de fréquence
cardiaque en blanc et en rouge c'était
l'école alors je vais l'accompagner
ça s'appelle c'est une course en ardèche
qui s'appelle l'ardéchoise 90 km et 1500
mètres de dénivelé alors j'étais à côté
de lui parce que j'avais mis un
cardiofréquencemètre sur le vélo pour
capter ces données être sûr que j'ai zay
et je vu avec sidération que il montait
à 5 57 battements par minute alors que
normalement c'est 220 malaj parce que le
coeur est censé vieillir ne pas battre
pouvoir battre très vite
alors vous voyez qu'en fait il est
arrivé à stabiliser sa fréquence
cardiaque et la monte légèrement tout au
long de l'ascension du col
je peux vous dire que j'étais accroché
derrière son vélo enfin j'essaie de
pédaler moi aussi mais c'était très dur
je me disais pourtant j'ai la moitié de
son âge
voilà mais c'était dur quand même et cet
homme là
je n'ai pas dit mon âge donc vous allez
pouvoir déduire le sien mais là je vais
devoir me griller donc révélé son âge
dont vous allez en déduire le mien il à
104 ans et demi et demi là c'est comme
les enfants on rajoute au demi parce que
le truc c'est d'arriver à 105 à 100 sa
commande novembre 0 c'est robert
marchand notre recorman du monde de vélo
de leur vélo
il fait 27 km dans leur ai essayé de
faire 25 km dans l'eure c'est quand on
va prendre son vélo pour faire les
courses
ces 12 15 voilà donc il aida table il a
établi le record de l'heure à 101 ans à
23 km heure et l'a battu à 103 ans à 25
km heure donc il a augmenté son golden
axe souris voilà ce qui se passe quand
on fait rien la consommation d'oxygène
en ordonner diminué xi inexorablement
sur fion à mesure de la prise d'âge en
abscisses et heureusement cette pente
douce mais inexorable peut s'inverser
on a une plante verte et faire comme
notre marathonien de 101 ans qui a
arrêté sa carrière
1 une ré augmentation de la consommation
d'oxygène à tout âge
donc on peut les choisir maintenant
quand vous allez sortir prendre et on
peut être une collection mais qui va
vous donner la force pouvoir repartir
et c'est ce que j'essaierai de vous
convaincre de faire on continue donc
ceci à la connaissance de soi donc la
connaissance de soi s'améliore à tout
âge par la course et ça c'est quelque
chose d'intéressant mais aussi quand on
se connaît bien on court mieux donc
sadoul à double sens et quand on fait un
marathon
on a une variation une oscillation de la
vitesse de course maintenant on a des
capteurs de toutes sortes qui nous
permettent de mieux comprendre ce qui se
passe dans notre corps est ce que l'on
produit effectivement quand on quand on
court
alors maintenant l'objet de mon travail
c'est de comprendre cette variation de
vitesse optimale qui nous permet d'aller
plus vite que si nous étions allés à
vitesse constante de retrouver cet
instinct d'ailleurs quand on observe
encore une fois les animaux les chiens
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu un chien
qu'à marquer des temps de passage sur
une main et qui couvrent à vitesse
constante comme on nous a appris à
l'école à le faire pour avoir une bonne
note au bac il fallait courir allure
régulière magique il faut être
régulièrement et régulier voilà donc
c'est la fraternité c'est tout ce qu'on
veut donc à des travaux avec des
mathématiciens qui nous font aller plus
loin dans la compréhension de ce qui se
passe quand on fait les choses pompe
année mans on compte en fait les choses
avec des indications précises sourit il
faut surtout pas suivre le rythme imposé
voyez ici qu'il y a des personnes qui
sont payés pour faire le billet vert
vous avez un magnifique drapeau en
quatre heures c'est à dire que tous les
gens qui veulent courir en quatre heures
marathon s'agglutinent derrière ce
porteur de drapeau
il faut surtout pas faire ça il faut
courir avec sa sensation souhait
alors effectivement bon ben si on était
sourd
on sent quand même des choses qui se
passent dans notre corps et le cerveau
finalement est un merveilleux
intégrateurs et il importe de comprendre
quel est le signal
quelques l intégration d toustou signaux
biochimiques le taux d'acidité d'un cent
le rythme respiratoire la fréquence
cardiaque
tous ces signaux là comme on les intègre
pour choisir sa variation de vitesse
optimale c'est ce que j'appelle la
signature de vitesse qui nous est propre
et qui peut changer avec les fatin qui
peut évoluer avec l'entraînement et
c'est ce que j'essaie de comprendre
il veut savoir accélérer et vous savoir
ralentir
on a tous une signature de vitesse alors
j'ai le mauvais goût de mettre des
analyseurs ça passe par des mesures de
signaux finalement alors c'est la mesure
de la consommation d'oxygène en temps
réel on analyse chaque cycle
respiratoires donc pendant tout un
marathon même on a fait l'ascension du
mont blanc avec cet appareil là c'est ce
qui permet de mesurer la consommation
d'oxygène et tous les facteurs
respiratoires asthme cardiaque associés
et emmené en même temps mesurent la
vitesse pour permettre de trouver sa
propre signature de vitesse qui nous
permet de maintenir un état stable
physiologique une toute nouvelle
expérience cette année donc avec qu à
véronique j'ai fait le pari de de courir
deux fois moi de m'entraîner deux fois
mois
trouvez toujours extraordinairement
exactement ça c'est impressionnant
ses impressions après 42 km voilà je
viens d'arriver et
suis je les jambes comme si j'avais pas
cool
effectivement ce monsieur faisait 120 km
par semaine et je les privait de 60 km
il en faisait plus que 60 c'est un jeune
cadre dynamique un cadre donc un
ingénieur et il n'avait pas le temps de
s'entraîner ça tombait bien donc je vous
ai permis de courir main et de pouvoir
réaliser une grande performance en lui
prédisant sa variation de vitesse
optimale qui l'a suivi parce qu'il
n'avait pas du tout confiance en lui
donc on est obligé de repasser par du
positif par des temps de passage
calculé par un algorithme que j'ai mis
au point en fonction de la force de
l'efficacité cardiaque de l'acidose et
de critères perception tout ça faisant
une consommation d'oxygène et qui me
permet de dégager un profil énergétique
une sorte de radar avec une note de 1 à
4 chacun de ces quatre items derrière
lesquelles se cachent 20 variable donc
qu'ils sont issus de mesures de
mécanique physiologique et perceptive à
partir d'un test auto administré à l'utt
est facile sprint vitesse moyenne en
rouge vitesse dur et en gris vitesse
très dur est de nouveau facile donc on
s'administre un test auto perçu sans
regarder aucune vitesse à partir duquel
j'établis votre radar énergétique qui va
me permettre d'avoir une signature de
vitesse qui va guider la personne et
donc avec la maintenance d'accélération
décélération puisque en fait je obligé
de réapprendre à la personne à avoir sa
bonne signature énergétique qui est
implémenté dans une montre que vous
veniez au centre qu'on a développés qui
s'appelle e mc2 expertise de ma course
connectés marques déposées
mais j'espère avoir l'occasion de faire
comme boris vian la complainte la
complainte du progrès des emménagés les
peluches patate etc
j'aimerais bien que tous ces objets
connectés disparaissent donc je
programme propre obsolescence ce soir
officiellement pour pouvoir éviter
d'avoir besoin de ces objets mais pour
l'instant on en a quand même besoin donc
pas tout de suite obsolescence pour
éviter ce moi même genre de choses
je crois qu'elle la boule ou à la
vitesse qu'en france voilà et essayer
d'être gentil avec soi même et
d'accepter de lâcher prise et
d'accélérer quand il faut on peut pas
être toujours à vitesse constante
merci
et